-Please help me welcome the one,
the only, Matthew McConaughey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Breakin' rocks
in the hot sun ♪
♪ I fought the law,
and the law won ♪
♪ Needed money
'cause I got none ♪
♪ I fought the law,
and the law won ♪
♪ Breakin' rocks
in the hot sun ♪
♪ I fought the law,
and the law won ♪
♪ I needed money
'cause I got none ♪
♪ I fought the law,
and the law won ♪
♪ Breakin' rocks
in the hot sun ♪
♪ I fought the law,
and the law won ♪
♪ I needed money
'cause I got none ♪
♪ I fought the law,
and the law won ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Matthew McConaughey.
Matthew McConaughey, welcome to
"The Tonight Show" here
in Austin, Texas, at U.T.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I have to ask you a few
questions while you're here.
Thank you for being here.
You could live anywhere in
the world if you wanted to.
Why do you choose to
live in Austin?
-Well, first off,
I am a proud Texan.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was born in South Texas.
I was raised
in East Texas and, yes,
now I hang my hat
right here in Austin, Texas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
One of the great things about
Austin is to make it here,
all you really got to do is
be yourself.
You can be a cowboy,
you can be a hippie,
you can be an American Indian,
an Asian, lesbian,
white, black, brown, yellow,
a blue-haired dwarf,
and you are welcome in Austin.
-You are, yeah.
-You really are.
-That's the thing --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We got a very lyrical city.
But what I think unites
all that diversity
I was talking about is --
we have a cowboy code
and we have a sense of common
values that we all rally behind.
In Austin, nobody's too good,
but everybody's good enough.
We don't lie, cheat, and steal.
We're an optimistic people.
We're resilient.
We're friendly. We're fair.
We respect and value ourselves
and we respect
and value each other.
We do not chase lawsuits.
No, we do not chase lawsuits.
We do break a sweat because we
pay the duty to live here
and we know that living here
and what we have here --
it's not free.
No, no.
That is how we're living here.
And guess what.
It's a lot cooler because we do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And y'all know what
I'm talking about.
To all newcomers -- and we got
125 a day coming here --
alright, if you don't want
to come here
and respect our values
and our tradition
and our core soul,
please keep on flyin'.
Drive on by.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
Everyone has been
so awesome to us.
Not just me, but
my whole crew and everybody.
I mean, people can recognize me,
but everybody, top to bottom,
have been talking about it,
how nice everyone's been to me.
Like, "Jimmy, you should go
to this place.
You should go to this place.
Oh, do you want a beer?
Do you want this?
Do you want --" I was like,
"Yeah, I do want a beer
and I do want that."
But they're like, "You want me
to give you a ride home?"
I go, "No, I'm good, man.
I'm good, I'm good. Thank you."
-Yeah.
-But you walked out here through
a sign that said, "M.O.C."
-Yes.
-"Minister of Culture."
-Yes, sir.
-What does that mean to you?
-So, alright, as
Minister of Culture,
I want to champion certain
guiding principles that we have.
Some of them I just spoke of,
you know?
-Yeah.
-Principles that are the
soul of Austin,
that are the soul of
the University of Texas.
We've earned our stripes.
-Yeah.
-And now we're growing.
We want to grow our heritage.
We need to maintain
and share those same values
as we were growing
and embracing progress.
-Do you like like
"Keep Austin weird"?
Is that --
-"Keep Austin weird" is great.
It's been around for decades.
It started --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It started to preserve
small businesses in Austin.
And it's great,
and I don't think
it should go anywhere.
I do think, though, that now
that Austin is coming into
a 2.0 stage, that there's
something that encapsulates
"Keep Austin weird,"
plus a little bit more.
And I think we should remind
ourselves daily
that we need to keep
Austin Austin, as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Now, Jimmy, this city --
the values that
I'm talking about.
This city and this university --
I get these values
because this city
and this university
has shown me those values
for the last 30 years
of my life here.
-And now you're a full-on --
You're a professor here...
-Yes, sir.
-...at the school.
And you will be teaching
"Script to Screen."
-Yes, sir.
-What it is like to be
in a class with
Matthew McConaughey
as a teacher?
-I think it's fun to be
in my class.
It sure is fun to teach it.
-It is, yeah?
-Yeah, it's the class I wish
I would've had
when I was here at film school.
I noticed, about 15 years ago,
how different
the final film was from
the original script that I read.
So what I've done is created
a class that we
chronologically track
the original script
all the way through
the first assembly,
the final picture in a semester.
So it's putting
the science behind
the magic of movie-making
for storytellers of tomorrow.
-I want to say
happy belated birthday
to you, my friend.
You turned 50 years old.
Happy birthday.
-Yes, sir. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You look pretty good.
You look real good, buddy.
-It's the company I'm keeping.
-What I want to talk to
you about is how you celebrated,
-'cause I think that was --
It meant a lot to me.
I read about it.
But explain to everybody.
How did you celebrate your 50th?
Did you have a big party?
-I spent time with my family.
We also -- Myself and
Wild Turkey partnering up
with Operation BBQ Relief
and went out to Los Angeles
and served barbecue and food.
Prepared it and served it
to 20 different firehouses.
So as they're fighting
the fires out there,
there's a lot of people
in the front line.
They needed food.
They needed to put food
in the freezer.
So we went out and said --
gave them a "howdy"
and helped them out.
-I love that you do that.
I love that you give back.
You don't forget
where you came from.
And now you're teaching here
and you're doing that.
But one of the other big
milestones in your life is --
you joined Instagram
a couple days ago.
-Yes, on my birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Would you be kind enough
to take a selfie
with me and this
great crowd right now?
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I'll do it.
-Go Down there.
Down there, Matt.
-♪ I'll follow you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright, here we go.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, we got to
look this way.
-Alright, alright.
-You're facing the wrong way.
Alright?
Alright, this is controlled
chaos is what we call this.
All right, ready? Oh, wait.
We got to be -- One, two, three.
[ Cheers and applause ]